Paul Schwartz covers the Giants for the
New York Post kind enough to join us on
what has to be a very busy day maybe
surprising day initial reaction to this
Paul well Dan free agency hasn't even
started yet right you know I guess we
can't talk about any of this right
nothing's official my initial reaction
is very much surprised I wouldn't say
shocked just because there was so much
buzz about a possible deal but let's
face it when you trade away a mega
superstar like Odell Beckham jr. a great
player I mean no one questions the fact
that he's a great player and he's not
old and he was signed to a contract it's
it's got to send reverberations around
the whole organization and this one
certainly will I guess I'm wondering
that you go 5 and 11 or another 5 and 11
season we're where the Giants may be
made aware a little bit quicker with
what happened with Antonio Brown that
this was gonna happen with Odell Beckham
jr. so let's get in front of this before
we're behind it well there's no question
they looked at what happened with
Antonio Brown and saw that the market
just completely evaporated for a great
receiver you know a better receiver in a
lot of people's minds then Odell Beckham
although he is a bit older but you know
I don't think Dan this was a case of the
giant saying we have to trade this guy
let's put him on the market let's see we
can get you know I felt though long they
would have to be blown away not shopping
him but fielding calls they would have
to be blown away in a deal of for
Beckham and I'm not sure if this
actually qualifies as blown away but a
first-round pick a third-round pick and
a a good play or a good young player and
safety Jabril Peppers is light years
better than what the Steelers ended up
getting so in that way the Giants struck
while the iron's hot but I think this
was a case where you know fans will have
to decide whether this was being
actually blown away in the trade as you
they move forward would you rather have
the Browns future or the Giants future
well look there's no question the Browns
I think are the hottest team in football
this year I'm not saying they're the
best team but no the Browns future is
tremendous now they had a lot of salary
cap money they have a quarterback going
into a second year they have Odell
Beckham who's only 26 they have
you know just a slew of tremendous
talent and an array of defensive and
offensive players I think if you would
talk to 30 teams in the NFL the vast
majority of them would say I'll sign up
for that roster the Browns have right
now
all right the strategy for the Giants in
the draft is going to be what well they
have 12 picks so the strategy is going
to be probably getting rid of some of
those picks um I still think Dan right
now sitting here the Giants have two
first round picks now a six this number
six pick and the 17 pick
I don't think at number six they go for
a quarterback I mean I just don't think
at this point they are looking at Dwane
Haskins and saying he is our guy that
has to replace Eli I could be wrong but
that's not the way I'm thinking right
now but after trading Odell and
presumably I assume bringing Eli Manning
back for his final year in his contract
I think they have to get the next young
quarterback on this roster whether it's
at the 17th pick that they got from the
the Browns either it's maybe getting the
guy in the second round or I still think
the Josh Rosen scenario is fascinating
and one the Giants must at least
investigate what do you think it would
take to get Josh Rosen well if they
don't have to give up their 6th round
pick and I don't know this number six
pick in the draft and I don't know if
they would have to give up the 17th pick
but now they do have a second
first-round pick they can give up at 17
to get him I would try for the second
round to pick that number 37 overall I
don't think the Cardinals are going to
be in a position if they really want to
take calimary at number one they got to
take what they can get for Josh Rosen
and just admit they made a mistake on
him and move on you know to the Phenom
quarterback who that coach seems to love
so you know I would not give up a ton
for him but if I can give him for the
number the second-round pick I would do
it in a heartbeat because I think the
Giants liked Rosen last year did the
Jets have a good day yesterday oh yes I
mean the Jets only in New York could the
jet eventually come up with levy on bail
and not make the back page of the New
York Post right that's what they'll
Beckham getting sent away goes right I
mean levy on bail is a surefire
slam-dunk back page and it happened late
and it happened after Odell got traded
but
yes the Jets look Dan we know what
happens in free agency the teams with a
hundred million dollars are going to
spend spend spend they're going to be
the big winners in the middle of March
right now and often in the short term it
is a big win for those teams in the long
term not so much so but yes the Jets
have made a bunch of good moves they've
improved their defense and you know levy
on bail improves every offense in the
league except maybe ones with say Kwan
Barclay and Todd Gurley good stuff Paul
I know it's a busy day we appreciate
your time as always
anytime Dan thank you Paul Schwartz for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]